here's a sound wave and here's its
inverse combine them and you have
silence that's the basic idea behind
noise canceling headphones but it takes
a lot of technology to make that
seemingly simple science possible we
have 15 millionths of a second to
measure the noise run it through a
little DSP processor compute that
inverse signal and pop it out through
the driver here's how they work
one way to visualize acoustic waves that
I like to use is a slinky John rule has
spent the last decade developing new
algorithms for personalizing noise
cancellation performance in Bose
headphones we draw them as sine waves as
if something's going back and forth or
up and down but what's really happening
is that these vibrations are actually
propagating through the air the medium
has stayed fixed but you can see that
pulse of energy sort of running through
the length of it because sound is just
waves you can cancel a sound wave by
introducing an equal and opposite wave
so what you've got is you've got an
incoming sound wave and the way
destructive interference works is we say
hey if I could generate an equal and
opposite signal right I could generate
the signal
that's the inverse of that and if I sum
those two things together I'll be left
with a flat line I'll be left with zero
pressure and that will be interpreted by
my brain as the noise having been
canceled Bose was the first company to
develop noise reduction technology for
headphones Dr Bose was coming back on an
overseas flight and got very frustrated
by the fact that airplanes were very
noisy we can control all sorts of other
stuff why can't we control noise the
first application that we looked at was
of canceling noise on airplanes Pilots
wore its earliest prototypes in 1986.
while the technology has gotten more
sophisticated the basic science Remains
the Same active noise cancellation
requires a few main components an outer
microphone to track incoming noise an
inner microphone the track sound waves
that make it inside your ear and also
checks if more environmental noise than
expected is making it through a digital
signal processor to run some algorithms
Based on data from the mics and the
speaker which cancels the background
noise while also playing the music or
Sound you want to hear think about how
fast this has to happen the sound is
obviously propagating at the speed of
sound right which is 343 meters per
second if you think about that in terms
of the thickness of an earbud it's
getting from the outside of the earbud
to the inside of the earbud in about 15
microseconds so that's millionths of a
second we're doing math as fast as we
can to basically cancel it out before it
gets in because everyone's ears are
differently shaped active noise
cancellation requires algorithms that
can be tuned based on the user Bose for
instance does this by playing a welcome
chime and monitoring feedback from the
internal microphone to customize noise
canceling filters accordingly this
requires a lot of testing to make sure
the algorithms work on a wide range of
users in all types of noisy environments
but eliminating background noise is just
the first step the next is figuring out
what noise to remove based on the
context I think it's really important to
recognize that noise is not bad that
noise is critical to my brain critical
to my body my brain uses it to create
richer experiences to fill in what's
missing which is all the time poppy
Chrome was previously the chief
scientist at Dolby Laboratories where
she worked for more than a decade she's
LED teams focused on emergent
Technologies and platforms that impact
sensory systems when you think about
noise canceling technology I like to
sort of separate it into three different
categories you know there's passive
noise canceling or passive noise
reduction which is effectively an ear
plug the second layer would be active
noise reduction it's Dynamic to the
system but it's dealing with what we
would call stationary sound sounds that
are you know consistent they're
continuous or they're predictable
examples of that might be a generator or
airplane noise not all the sounds in the
airplane but that General Rumble those
low frequency sounds you're trying to
get rid of they're pretty predictable
for these predictable noises current
noise canceling algorithms can quickly
identify unwanted sound waves and cancel
them out beyond that things get harder
and then the next layer which is I think
where you know the future is still
evolving is when you start being able to
really cancel out things that are what
you would call non-stationary noise
things that might be a dog barking and
you know those elements that happen
where you can't predict them and you
might be able to have a expectation that
they're going to happen but they're
things that aren't continuous and aren't
constant but sometimes after your
technology has gone through so many
steps to reduce background noise you
want it back airpods Pro have a
transparency mode where they recreate
the normal sound of your environment
other noise canceling earbuds also offer
modes to help you hear your surroundings
like Bose's aware mode and Sony's
Ambient sound mode that preserve enough
background noise to keep you alert to
your surroundings when you build a
technology that's supposed to map to a
human experience you need to understand
how the human system perceives change or
perceives that element you're building
and then that becomes how your algorithm
behaves so that you have a continuous
experience in the world so you need Labs
where you can remove or control every
other element
noise cancellation could soon solve more
complex problems like using machine
learning to seamlessly and intelligently
eliminate unwanted sounds or voices
across various contexts adaptive audio
which is coming to Apple's airpods Pro
soon combines noise cancellation with
the transparency mode so you can only
hear the important sounds around you so
you can stay present within your
environment while distracting noises are
automatically reduced
it's the thing that everybody wants
right they want to make certain noises
go away so they still want to hear some
things they don't want to hear other
things and can I can you just give me a
set of headphones that you know just
cancels the stuff I don't want to hear
that's not a thing that we're offering
yet but that's the kind of thing that
that is being worked on
foreign foreign